- Ohhhh.
- Uh, oh that's a good question.
- Hypothetically I would go gay for,
oh you worded it differently there.
(upbeat music)
- I identify as straight.
- I am a straight man.
- My name is Alaska and
I am a straight man.
(romantic music)
- Uhhhh who would I go gay for?
- Daniel Craig, Mr. Bond himself.
He's got, you know the peck
ledge, which is pretty nice.
The accent is just an immediate sell.
- Kylo Ren or Adam Driver, cuz of
those curly locks and that schnoz.
- I would go full on
gay for Justin Bieber.
He turned his life around and
that's a really attractive trait to me.
He's just so smooth and beautiful.
- There's only one hunky man
that reigns true in my heart,
and that has to be Dwayne
'The Rock' Johnson.
Of course it's the sex appeal,
it's the muscles, it's the
good looks, it's the acting
prowess, and the rock bottoms.
(romantic music)
- I want to know the
frailty behind the muscles.
That's the biggest thing
before we get into it.
It'd be just like holding his
arm like this, and I'm like,
"It's okay, Rock," and I'll
grab his big, muscular arm over.
- Well I know Justin loves to skate,
so I'd take him to a skatepark.
You know, maybe he'd buy me a slurpee.
We could hang out.
- Probably like an East-Asian
like art museum I would think.
Then get boba.
If he's not into boba though, that
like an automatic, that's a deal breaker.
- He's got the whole Bond
thing going, I'd kind of
expect him to take me out on a date.
There'd be like an element of
danger and then we'd escape.
And then you know, cuddle.
- The Rock fans call themselves
rock climbers, so I'm just
sayin' they better move
the hell out the way
cuz I'm climbin' that mountain.
(romantic music)
- ♫Is it too late now to say fuck me♫
I want to sing that to you Justin.